foreign
[Music]
Tracy Fisher I'm an associate professor
with the Tulane National Primate
Research Center and the Tulane
University School of Medicine
today I'm going to talk to you about
neuropathology of SARS Kobe 2 infected
aged non-human primates
now as I'm sure that all of you are
already aware SARS Kobe 2 infection is
associated largely with respiratory
disease however early in the pandemic we
recognize that extra pulmonary
complications were also a significant
concern including a number of
neurological manifestations
which would suggest or indicate that
there is some impact on the brain with
infection
so in response to the pandemic very
early uh even before the um
the CDC or the who had actually
designated this as an uh pandemic we
started a pilot study of sarsko V2
infected
non-human primates using African green
monkeys
which were wild caught from Saint Kitts
approximately 16 years old and included
two males and two females as well as
Reese's macaques which were from our
specific pathogen free Colony here at
the Tulane National Primate Research
Center these animals were approximately
13 to 15 years old and included three
males and one female in this pilot study
to develop a non-human primate model of
infection
now the animals were inoculated with the
what's referred to as the Washington
strain this was the first isolate from
the United States and we used two routes
of challenge one was through a
multi-root mucosal challenge which
included the conjunctival nasal
pharyngeal and intratracheal roots this
was performed on two of each species
um and we also did an aerosol challenge
again two of each species were included
with this challenge
now all animals regardless of the
challenge
established infection within that first
week and this was defined by RT qpcr of
swabs or brushes taken from multiple
collection sites and you can see on the
right side of the screen the different
areas that we sampled from including the
buccal nasal pharyngeal bronchial battle
and rectal roots and you can see that
all of the animals
develops some infection which was
sustained for the majority of the
animals throughout the study of
approximately 28 days now all of the
animals did survive to the study
endpoint except for two of our African
green animals
who had both developed acute respiratory
distress syndrome or arms and this was
seen again just in the African green
monkeys they're both female and it
one one had been challenged to the
aerosol route and one through the
mucosal route so that did not appear to
be uh the issue for who developed
infection
or Arts now all of the animals had
actually
demonstrated some degree of pulmonary
pathology the African green monkeys had
pathology that range from minimal to
severe as you can see with panels A and
C and C you can see this is from an
animal who had developed arts and you
can see the significant lesions and
pathology within the lung the rhesus
mccax also showed pathology that ranged
from minimal to moderate so they had a
relatively less severe disease than what
we had seen with the African green
monkeys however they still did develop
disease all of the animals did have
lesions in the lungs that were
multifocal and randomly distributed and
this is actually published in the
American Journal of pathology
by Robert Blair who is a Veterinary
pathologist here at the Tulane National
Primate Research Center
now all of the animals did have some
productive infection in the lung too as
you can see here
um the top panels are from the Reese's
macaques and the bottom are from the
African green monkeys and you can see
this uh bright pink or deep pink color
which is identifying uh SARS Kobe 2
nucleocapsid in the lung through
immunohistochemistry
now of course our interest was in the
brain and at the time of this
investigation there was very little
information coming from uh humans so we
did a sampling of the brain looking at
the primary lobes frontal parietal
occipital and temporal lobes of the
basal ganglia and cerebellum as well as
the lower brain stem including the ponds
and the medulla
foreign
hypothesis when we approach this work
was that we would see neuroinflammation
in the brain and this is largely based
on the fact that we have a significant
inflammatory event that occurs in the
periphery that we anticipated would
translate to the CNS compartment based
on earlier work with viral infections
and so our first study included uh
looking for at neuroinflammation we
first looked at iba1 which is a pan
microglial marker and this is seen even
in normal brain or non-affected brain
where we would anticipate that the
microglia are expressing iba1 so iba1 is
upregulated in the context of
inflammation and we can see that here in
all three panels in panel a you can
actually see where the
morphological changes are occurring in
the microglia as well as some changes in
how they uh are spread through their own
territory so normally microglia like to
maintain their own territory and you'll
see them start to Cluster up you can see
this in panel a in panel B you can see a
nodular lesion and then in C we saw some
accumulation of microglia or round blood
vessels
um suggestive again of inflammation and
something happening there at the
blood-brain barrier
we also saw up regulation of hladr this
is an MHC class II molecule that is
normally a normal brain or non-affected
brain we do not detect however in the
context of infection we do see up
regulation of hladr and you can see
really nicely in panel a those
morphological changes that we see in
activated microplia where we have
retracted and thickened processes and
then you can also see in panel B where
they're starting to accumulate in
certain areas and then in panel C you
can see this as a nodular lesion
now wherever we see
microglial activation we would also
anticipate that the astrocytes are also
going to be responsive and so we uh we
use the pan astrocyte marker a
gliofibulari acidic protein and
performed immunohistochemistry and you
can see both in the rhesus macaques in
the African green monkeys this is areas
of the same brain this is the cerebellum
and you can see in the white matter of
the rhesus mccaxon the African greens
that are infected we have significant
upregulation of gfap
astrocytes also like the microglia like
to retain their own personal domains and
you can see there's they're losing this
they're starting to accumulate and then
we also see retracted processes and
larger cell bodies than we would expect
in uh under physiological conditions
so while this uh inflammation was very
interesting to us
in infection there were some other
striking features that kind of shifted
our attention into other directions so
one of the most prominent things that we
observe when looking at the brain tissue
was what appeared to be neuronal injury
or even neuronal death and so what I'm
showing you here is if you look in panel
a or the only panel that we're showing
here this is a row of nice healthy
purpinji cells in the cerebellum and you
can see here in panel a that in the
context of infection we saw large
regions of these purkinje cells with
shrunken cell bodies
picnotic nuclei where you see it highly
condensed chromatin that tend to stain
or pick up the hematoxylin and stain of
very dark blue it almost appears black
we also saw intracellular vacuolation
you can see here in panel a with the
arrows pointing and then evacuation of
the neural pill
we also saw this in other brain regions
in panel B we're showing brain stem
where you also see the vacculation of
the neural pill and pignatic nuclei that
you can see the asterisk in there that
is indicating in a region of that and
also we see shrunken cell bodies
in the in the brain stem
and this is indicative of our suggestive
of neural deaths so we started to
explore that a little bit further to uh
to confirm or verify that it is in fact
death that we're seeing and so the first
thing that we looked at was Flora Jane C
this is a special stain that stains
degenerating neurons
um it's not fully understood how this
works but it is hypothesized to bind to
the anionic and ionic elements that are
within the inner layer of the cell
membrane which would only be exposed in
the context of cell death and you can
see this these large areas of the
purkinje cells that are staining with
the fluoro Jade C suggestive of neuronal
death neuronal degeneration
so we also looked at pleeds caspase 3.
now as you know may know inactive Pro
Cast Space 3 exists in the cytoplasm and
is cleaned by initiator caspases such as
caspase eight nine regardless of whether
it's an intrinsic or extrinsic signal
that would indicate
a push towards cell death and so we get
this cleavage event and formation of
tetramer which is in its active form and
once we see active caspase 3 this
indicates a commitment of the cell
uh to undergo apoptosis
so what we found was that again here we
have those purkinje cells in panel a and
you can see the the
cytoplasm as well as the nucleus showing
cleavecast phase 3 positivity by the
purkinje cells as well as other cells
within that purkinje cell layer we saw
it in other regions as well on panel B
we're showing a brain stem and you can
see several areas or several cells which
appear to be caspase 3 positive
suggesting that these cells are
committed to undergoing death cell death
now
this was a
actually a rare feature
myelinbackulation it was rarely seen we
only saw it in two of the animals
um however this was a relatively small
pilot study
um so what was interesting about this is
that we do have reports of myelin
demyelinating disease in the context of
infection so although this was a rare
event we thought it was worth uh
reporting it's unclear if this is is
caused by the virus however we only did
see it in the infected animals in this
small study now more frequently we saw a
number of micro hemorrhages in the
context of infection you can see this in
all of the panels a through D show
infected animals and in at her actually
our age match control animals that
underwent the same
procedures as those are infected animals
and you can see there we have some micro
hemorrhages in these animals which does
occur with aging we did quantitate this
and in total brain we do see a trend
towards an increase in the number of
micro bleeds in the areas of brain that
we investigated
this did not reach statistical
significance except for in the basal
ganglia where we saw a significant
increase of these hemorrhages in the
context of infection as compared to our
non-infected but age match controls
now we saw a number of these bleeds that
appeared to some appeared to be
Associated maybe with uh with a thrombus
While others did not appear to be so we
wanted to explore this further and so we
we had performed immunohistic chemistry
using cd61 this is a factor that
participates in platelet aggregation
through its complex with cv41 and a
number of other factors and as you can
see here in both the infected and
control animals we had some cv61
positive uh
Crombie in the blood vessel Lumen and
you can see that
in a through D however we also saw some
bleeds in which you can see in both E
and F
that uh
that do not appear to be associated with
the thrombus so we wanted to quantitate
this because we saw this in both the
infected and the non-infected animals
and our quantitative
demonstrated that
largely animals that are infected had
a more a greater frequency of
microhemorrhages that were not
associated with cd61 positivity
as compared to our controls this is true
for all of the animals except for agm5
she was one of our age-matched African
green
controls and she had a significant
number of bleeds in her brain as you can
see we have a total of 19 here and she
actually looks a little bit more like
our infected animals who had a greater
frequency of cv61 negative in the in the
purple versus cd61 positive in the pink
bleeds and this may suggest that we have
a thrombolytic factors that are that are
have removed the thrombus and so it's
not seen in this section
um or it could suggest that there are
other mechanisms for uh these bleeds
which we want to explore further now of
course a really important question in
all of this is where is the virus so in
our study which did not have the
olfactory bulb
um
we did not see virus very frequently in
these regions of the brain we did uh in
collaboration with Tony who at the
Tulane School of Medicine we performed a
a
[Music]
analysis of virus and whole brain
sections and you can see that these are
largely in agreement with uh with rare
virus so it's really just a lying above
the
um or the the bars above this line here
and you can see that the cerebellum
basal ganglia brain stem frontal lobe as
well as cerebral spinal fluid
um only showed
virus detection in some animals and this
was largely what we had seen by
immunohistochemistry where sometimes we
would see the virus and and
specific brain regions while other times
we did not in the same animal so it was
really rare when we did see it it
appears to collocalize with fond
dolivarum factor which is uh
an endothelial cell marker which you can
see in the panel to the right with uh
where you have collocalization of found
the LeBron factor and the nucleocapsid
of the virus
now to gain additional insight into what
might be causing this injury we looked
at some of the clinical measures this
was not a study that was set up
specifically for the brain so there's a
number there Still Remains a number of
questions however one thing that we did
observe was that all of the animals
largely
experience some minor mild but chronic
hypoxemia as you can see with this
reduction in in oxygen that was recorded
for the majority of the animals we also
saw an increase in CO2 which may suggest
impaired gas exchange
um we hypothesized that this might lead
to tissue hypoxia as well as vascular
injury from the hyper immune response
due to the infection as well as reduced
oxygen and so to begin to explore this
question we looked at
hypoxia-inducible Factor one alpha so
the alpha subunit is normally under
normoxic conditions it would be degraded
however in the context of hypoxia this
is upregulated so we get increased
transcription of the protein as well as
stabilization of the protein where it
does not get
degraded and we saw a significant
uh hif1 Alpha upregulation in the
context of infection that appeared
largely around the vasculature and we
quantitated this this is through a
non-biased quantitation software uh
called Halo and you can see both in the
brain stem and the basal ganglia we had
a significant upregulation whereas in
the cerebellum there was a trend towards
an increase in if one alpha in the
context of infection however it did not
reach statistical significance
so animal models are only as good as how
well they translate to human disease and
among humans we see uh similar injury in
the brain as what we were seeing in the
animals as well as clinical
manifestations that would support what
we're finding microscopically in the
brain
this includes a number of different
types of disease and injury including
cerebral vascular disease
encephalopathy where patients might a
large number of patients will present
with altered mental status or
encephalytic presentation and this was
reported with and without
confirmatory Imaging a virus in the cnns
appears to be rare in the CSF it's
rarely found when it is investigated at
least according to the to the number of
um
case reports and case series that are
out there
autopsy brain tissue it has rarely found
however this is inconclusive and we in
there may be some areas of brain that
are more vulnerable to infection than
others
an autopsy brain we see widespread
neural inflammation with a limited
number of nodules and cuffs is similar
to what we had seen in the animals we
see lymphocyte accumulation but this is
generally in the context of encephalitis
which is thankfully rare
um and there's a number of reports now
that have suggested
hypoxic ischemic injury
neuronal injury and loss as well as
microvascular injury in human subjects
so we had done a
a systematic review and meta-analysis
while we were doing our work in the
animals to get a better understanding of
how the virus might contribute to CNS
injury or disease and so we included
different studies in our quantitative
ellices are our meta-analysis in this
and it is uh reported this has been
published last year and frontiers of
Beijing neuroscience
so but I will briefly discuss what our
findings were
and in this uh
meta-analysis we actually excluded
anybody who may have a pre-existing uh
CNS disease that
would confound
our understanding of what
contribution the virus is actually
making to CNS disease
so of these reports it included a
2390 subjects and you can see we
categorize their uh different
manifestations and these different
categories cerebrovascular disease
peripheral neuropathies encephalopathies
demyelinating disease smell and or taste
disorders CNS inflammatory disease and
then we made a category of other where
symptoms were described however
they did not necessarily fall under
these other categories of disease and
what we found was that while smelling
taste and or taste disorders were the
most frequently observed or reported
cerebrovascular disease was second and
that was a pretty significant population
in our analysis when we stratified this
by age we see in individual's over were
at 50 years old this is a significant
risk for cerebral vascular disease in
the context of infection whereas smell
and or taste disorders appeared to be
more prominent among younger individuals
however it's important to note that some
severe critical
urgent uh CNS manifestations such as
cerebral vascular disease are also
reported in young individuals including
those under 19 years
so we correlated these different
manifestations with age and found that
cerebral vascular disease had a positive
correlation with increased age however
CNS inflammatory disease
taste and or smell disorders and our
category of other were the only other
categories Associated significantly with
age however this was an inverse
correlation
now these are uh
our correlation matrixes that show the
relationship of age with cerebral
vascular disease
or the different manifestations triple
vascular diseases the only one that
again was associated with an increase in
age
uh panel B uh shows that we have a
higher risk for severe critical disease
with age and then panel C just shows
that we have a increase for
comorbidities that are associated with a
severe or critical disease outcome
um
and these are higher among individuals
who are aged we do not really see any
sex differences which are
are included in panels D through f
now this puts it all together where we
have age and sex and how it's
associating with these different
neurological disease categories and you
can see the disease severity or the
comorbidities did not necessarily
correlate significantly with any
particular neurological disease outcome
although some were more
put an individual at a greater risk for
certain types of manifestations
foreign
so in conclusion we showed that infected
African green monkeys and rhesus
macaques are highly relevant animal
models of SARS cov2 infection they can
recapture what human disease and autopsy
findings are showing and they also
reveal brain injury even in animals that
did not develop severe respiratory
disease and this is a really important
outcome of this study where we were able
to actually look at the brain
microscopically in animals that would
have been that would not have succumbed
to disease whereas in humans we are only
able to look at the brain in this manner
after death so this is important as this
really shows a neuropathology may be a
common complication of infection we also
saw varying degree of neuropathology
including neuroinflammation uh
neurodegeneration
micro bleeds a number of
microhemorrhages and as mentioned in
frequent
myelinfaculation now I just want to
leave you with how this might be
important for individuals who experience
neurological symptoms of post-acute
sequelae of covid-19 or past which is
also referred to as long covid
um whereas
this is going to the neurological
manifestations likely reflect what area
of the brain is impacted the extent of
the injury and whether we get a complete
resolution of injury and this is a um as
an example I am pointing to a study from
2021 of Imaging individuals who had
experienced persistent impaired uh smell
and these individuals showed a reduction
in the metabolic activity in the
bilateral limbic cortices and I'm
showing that in the top picture what
that area of the brain would include and
the left insular cortex and again I'm
showing that here in the lower image now
there's also the question of whether
there's virus in the brain and if so
what cells are infected and do we get a
resolution of this infection in the
brain or is it an abortive infection
that could still impact the function of
the cells that it's infecting and then
whether or not we have a prolonged and
our augmented neuroinflammation that
does not get resolved and how this might
contribute to pathological brain aging
so in conclusion I'd like to acknowledge
all of the individuals who participated
in this work this was a huge under under
uh taking
um by a wonderful team of
veterinarians and scientists
and especially want to uh
recognize the efforts put out by the
individuals in my lab Lynn helmers and
Meredith Mayer that did the the bulk of
this work which is really labor
intensive
so I'd also like to acknowledge our
funding from the NIH
the fast grants for covid-19 and Tulane
University thank you very much